hi i'm eric and i'm the general sales
manager
here at move for less and today i'm with
sasha rojo
and she is one of the recipients for our
moving art community program
hi i'm sasha i was one of the recipients
for the moving our community program and
because of what's going on in the valley
she still doesn't have a place to move
but once she is ready we will get her
moved into her
new home i am here to
give some background on my story as far
as how
covet 19 has affected my myself and my
family
and as far as
our progression and what's been going on
with us
i was supposed to be moved into my new
place
but since of the the pandemic i still
haven't be able to find
or afford a new um residence
so as i'm sorting this out with my
family
it's been a very trying time to say the
least
um i was very hesitant to share my story
just because there is some
embarrassment that goes along with
homelessness but as of right now
we've been staying in our old um
storage it's in a laundry room area
and there's storage units that are
inside and me and my husband
have been shacked up in there it's like
a six by five foot space
so i mean it barely fits two people have
a few shelves in there
but other than that i'm just thankful
that i do have a place to sleep
my daughter lily is six months old
she's in the stages of crawling now
she's my big bundle of joy she likes to
smile
and suck on her toes
so she definitely keeps me motivated to
stay afloat and find something
secure pre-pandemic life was pretty good
secure stability um i was about eight
months pregnant when the pandemic
really blew up so my last trimester was
interesting
to say the least
basically very normal family lifestyle
you pay your bills on time nothing's
overdue food on the table
opposed to now going through this
let's say um may
may june that's really when it hit hard
for us
after my daughter was born those were
the crucial times
we just found out our daughter has was
it vsd
it's ventricular septal
defect it's where she has a hole in her
heart so
now she's really fragile and we really
can't take her anywhere so
um she's with relatives they're taking
care of her
while we're out floating around trying
to make something
of ourselves there's no way i could have
had my daughter lily with us
especially the last month it was 110 115
i mean that's no environment for at that
time five-month-old
baby no way especially with kovic going
on i mean
i don't want to expose her to anything
that could potentially get her sick
especially now that she's more fragile
you know i always think it could always
be a lot worse
i'm a believer in god and i will have a
strong faith
and i've been with my my husband my
fiance for 10 years
and even though we've been together so
long i mean it does
test us my fiance has been a union
bartender for a long time
so it's been very difficult for him not
to have his trade
and for myself like i said i work in
entertainment all the clubs are still
closed
so it's hard to put that on your resume
for a new place to live
if they're all still shut down it's hard
to find
something when you don't have an income
or a budget to factor
off of so like i said we've been waiting
for
unemployment for months and months and
months and each month i'm sure we all
think
oh it's going to come it's going to come
then they hit you with
i need to have more information i need
more verification then you wait another
30 days in another 30 days
so it's just stall tactics it's it's
very frustrating
august 19th since we got our eviction
notice
um realistically we've been looking at
places but it's hard to find something
when you don't have
an income or a budget to factor off of
so like i said we've been waiting for
unemployment for months and months and
months
i'll be honest since you know i know a
lot of people could
use hearing a similar story that you can
get through it and it's not
all bad um after we left our apartment
for our condo august 19th we were
evicted
um we fell through a loophole where our
lease was three months
and um since the eviction moratorium
only
um that was the word um
contents of the people that have
full-time leases we had he got evicted
so we called move for less last minute
and i said please come save
us and they were right there to help us
with everything the employees were
awesome
i know one man his name was drew i can't
remember his friend but they were
awesome
highly recommended i mean they were they
were the best
while she wasn't able to move due to all
the things going on here in southern
nevada
we were able to get her moved into our
storage unit within 24 hours
i mean it means a lot it means a lot
it's been really hard and i'm just happy
that
there's somebody out there that really
cares
in my own community and has helped us so
much and it has brought me
to believe that there are people out
there that will help
i'm sorry it's been very difficult
finding help um before i reached out to
remove for less
i was hitting charity after charity
churches
but they're so overwhelmed and booked up
that i couldn't get anything
and it was very frustrating and there
are times that you just want to give up
but i didn't have that option so i would
just keep going online making phone
calls
and that's when i reached out to move
for less and
i sent them an email and i was happy to
become one of their recipients so
i almost you know fell out and cried
when i got the phone call from eric
going through this time i mean i've had
my lows
um but to to be honest i think i've been
managing
well pretty well i always say that um
god doesn't give you more than you can
handle and i'm not saying you know to be
preachy or anything but
i really feel like the strong do survive
and this is just a test it's just a
temporary struggle and if anyone else is
having a hard time
just you know keep on pushing keep your
family close
and know that this won't last forever it
won't last forever
i want to say thank you move for less we
really appreciate you
our families gives us gives you guys our
sincerest you know gratitude and
humility let me shake your hand even
though i should rub elbows that's okay
yeah it's definitely our pleasure
absolutely it's our pleasure and i'm
glad we're able to get you
you know moved out in such a quick time
and help you as much as possible
and we have your stuff here safely so as
soon as you're ready and find a new home
uh we'll be ready to go thank you guys
thank you so much i mean you've helped
us so much just with that alone
i was so worried about losing everything
that we worked so hard for
and then having to start all over again
i mean that's detrimental on its own
so thank you guys we really really
really appreciate it it's truly our
pleasure and
we enjoy uh having the ability to help
families like uh like you all and uh
just do what we can to get you on to the
next chapter of your life
thank you
you